hello
everyone um I would like to introduce
Daniel he's a data sciencetist at uh ABN
Emeral and he'll talk about a quite
quite like interesting subject survival
analysis so thank you
Daniel thank you thank you very much uh
yeah thank you for very much for being
here choosing this talk among the other
ones that are existing parallel so
Daniel Sani I'm coming from applied
mathematics systems and control
background um I've been in different
domains from manufacturing cyber
security Healthcare and now in abro uh
Finance um the concepts I'm walking you
through originated from Healthcare how
are the applications are quite diverse
um the codes related to The Talk could
be found in my gith up P data Amsterdam
so basically uh survival analysis is
statistical uh basically method uh
started off in biomedical Sciences to
deal with the time until an invent of
Interest happens to to basically
investigate these type of problems the
other name of this uh let's say domain
is time to event analysis um it was
originally developed with the aim of
dealing with missing data so because in
healthcare there were they had a few
let's say samples they wanted to make
some conclusion from data but of course
maybe 50% or more than that of their
samples didn't let's say meet the event
that could have happened might have been
death of the patient or other things
however the techniques and tools
developed uh in this domain have let's
say they have gone to other domains from
sociology economics engineering and you
could you could while I would walk you
through the rest see it's a bit of a
super set of let's say classification
and regression um applications are for
example in healthcare you having a
patient the birth event is being
discharged from ICU and the death event
is basically getting once again back
into ICU and then you're looking at the
likelihood of the basically visiting ICU
uh given certain time period of course
it could be also in manufacturing when
you're doing predictive maintenance
device you started it it's in the desert
it might you know just suddenly
encounter
malfunction and then interested to
predict the time until the malfunction
of course there are censoring and
competing risks which might be a loss in
the desert or or just you know cats fire
you know just because of any reason not
predicted let's say maintenance wise of
course big problem churn also in
marketing you could also look at it uh
let's say customer credit risk in
finance um employment let's say uh
unemployment duration in let's say
economy what you're let's say looking at
is mostly a time a slot from start to
the finish of the study you have some
let's say samples of yours starting
somewhere between some of them already
maybe uh let's say started before but
you always have this missing data what
are these example of missing data for
example subject does not experience the
event when the study is over that's
subject two so the study is finished
still you have clients that they have
not churned yeah you were looking at in
your database you still have client that
they have not churned uh another use
case of that could be that the subjects
pass away or they have limited followup
so again for example
churn a client passes away or it might
be heal here and the let's say patient
is lost because of course loss of a data
is less likely in marketing because
hopefully they have more control of
their let's say clients and and of
course it could be the case that you
have left sensor on on the for last cage
that actually the event uh which is for
example INF inflicted with a disease
already started before even you start
the analysis so basically uh this this
domain is trying to address this missing
data problem and if you see uh it could
be casted as a classification problem if
you fix the time Horizon then you could
look at let's say uh let's say uh sample
that already let's say um encountered
the event within the time Horizon t or
not give them label one Zer and do a
classification the caveat is then you're
not predicting the time actually so
you're fixing the time the other aspect
if you want to go off with regression is
that you would look at the let's say
samples that already encountered this
let's say event and basically do a
regression analysis of course then you
have throw to throw away all of those
samples that you have not have not
already let's say encounter this
event so basically the taxonomy of the
methods in in survival analysis they
start similar to the other domains with
some descriptive methods basic let's say
visualization let's say statistical
analysis with univariate variables like
Vu coula mayor Nelson Allen I'll walk
you through the uh couple of Mayor
analysis but then it could go off also
to predictive analytic then you need
also some let's say uh measures of what
is a good let's say fit or not what am I
doing a good predictive modeling or not
so I will also mention that but then of
course there are very different methods
in the Predictive Analytics flavor it
starts with regression like let's say
Solutions all the way with tree based
Solutions and also Bas probabilistic
programming and neural network there are
different libraries that have
numerically implemented these that you
can benefit from the one in let's say Li
lifelines is the one that Clos is is the
closest to statistical Community uh
psyched survival based on top of cycle
learn uh PMC has some implementation XG
boost also has some implementation to
address this and also neural network so
I'll start off with basically the uh the
the statistic let's say statistical
flavors and in both of these so in all
of these method what you're trying to do
is basically trying to predict do
functions one of them is survival plot
that's nonincreasing so you normally
drops and the other one is cumulative
Hazard that is not decreasing that's
kind of increases but then what is
different from classical regression and
classification is you have one uh let's
say uh time let's say Horizon on the
x-axis and the probability on the y-
axis so it's a mixture of kind of give
you flavor of both of them uh so the
non-parametric estimators like c walk
you in a bit are basically a good uh
let's say candidate for the top let's
say curve survival function and if you
want to have a param non-parametric metc
for cumulative Hazard Nelson island is
also a good choice however there are
also parametric let's say estimators in
this community that based on the
distribution of your data you can
basically fit the data to your parameter
and then visualize well that there will
be a little bit off the conversation
that I'm going to have but I'm going to
start now here with KLA mayor
estimator they're very basic method me
and actually very useful so you could do
exploratory data analysis with this
method you could do also CLE analysis
with this method it helps you in
detecting cohort drift and data
drift and also helps with univariate
feature uh selection so it's very simple
is just calculating this let's say
function throughout time in an example
um you can see event the probability
that the event is not happening
basically it starts with 100% one
and the curve kind of starts uh
basically dropping every time an event
happens given the number of samples that
you have for example in this Cas is 10
then if one event happens you have 10%
drop the second event happens basically
is one out of 9 11% drop and all the way
there might be also sensoring that means
the uh the subject didn't experience
this event if it's a churn problem it
could be that the subject died while
still holding a product passed away um
and then those are the cases that
they're censoring so that means the
curve doesn't drop so it will stay the
same but of course if the next object
drops uh encounters the event the curve
drops then it would be one over six
because two already dropped two sensor
so six out of
10 this is a numerical example from from
a
432 basically prisoners that they were
under a
study they were released from Maryland
uh State
Prison half of them received financial
aid and the other half didn't and it was
totally at random so it was experimental
experimental study and they were
interested to look at okay what is the
effect of basically uh the the the
criminals getting rearrested in the
prisoner I mean this is a example also
in Lifeline coming from a scientific
paper on the x-axis you have a time
Horizon 52 weeks uh you see there are no
censoring basically no uh prisoners were
lost in the followup but there indeed
after 52 weeks you have censoring
because it's the type two censoring that
I mentioned on the first uh basically
page and of course you have basically um
uh criminals that have also getting God
rearrested so if you want to compare
this uh to to one another you could see
okay the blue one receive financial aid
they show a let's say uh a less
probability of getting rearrested sorry
uh they they show a higher probability
of not getting rearrested and the red
red ones are more probable to get
rearrested and if the Gap basically
between these two groups are
statistically significant which is
measured by this p value of log rank
test then you can say okay this
basically treatment is bringing added
value of course this is also something
that could be very the case in marketing
right you have your treatment and and
and control group you provide let's say
treatment and then uh you're interested
on the outcome I mean this was a luxury
of dealing with a problem that was
experimental study um so if you remove
this time component you get that to that
classical bar chart so you could kind of
see the amount of added value that this
time component brings into the
play
so it was experimental design study
randomized um I've got another example
which is not randomized I'll will walk
you through on the next slide but just
the let's say takeaways a cou mayor
curve is very powerful other example is
it helps you detecting cohort drifts so
let's assume you have a 20 years of data
you have you want to see if the uh let's
say your samples like how was the drift
in the first 10 year and the second 10
year so then you could uh uh plot these
against one another for example the red
one it's uh the latter 10 year the first
one the first let's say decade you could
see a quite a you know sharp let's say
reduction in the retention probability
so method helps you with identifying
cohort drift or cohort bias another was
it could be a causal analysis that you
are so this is a probability of a kidney
not rejecting uh so it's coming from
Healthcare you have patients undergoing
kidney transplantation and they want to
know okay are antibodies basically
important in pred in in in the
probability of the kidney getting lost
of course um they they want to let's say
numerically validate the scientific
let's say conjecture then what you would
do based on potential out you could do a
propensity let's say inverse propensity
waiting because you try to let's say is
donor specific antibody Rd exis in both
treatment and control group yes no then
you predict that then you would try to
penalize by the inverse of that your
population and then you can let's say
have also a couple of mirror of showing
that also it could be used in human
univariate feature selection so you
would have the probability of let's say
your client let's say churning a product
but of course based on their payment
method the blue one shows uh let's say
more customer turn than the red and the
green one it gives you a univariate uh
capability of looking
into um I want to move to the predictive
methods but before that also it's
important if you want to do prediction
we would have a metrics to measure is
this a good prediction or not there are
in the community root meanus square
methods of course but are a square but
they're not relevant when you have
sensoring data and that's one of the
added values that the survival analysis
and all of these uh methods trying to
bring to deal with this sensoring data
so then they are also introducing their
own let's say metrics for uh measuring
the goodness of prediction and that is
cindex or concordant index so what they
would do they basically look at the
number of concordant pays or the all
comparable pairs so if you look at this
a concordant pair would be um two
subjects undergoing failure undergoing
let's say say the event at certain time
let's say TI TJ if the prediction is
also consistent with ti bigger than TJ
and TI hat bigger than TJ hat then you
would say this is a concordant pair over
all of the uh basically um uh comparable
Pairs and the comparable pair could
change B based on if you have sensory or
not there are also other methods Brier
score and mean absolute error and they
are open if you're interested to uh
consider it separately
um a very basic method in the predictive
Paradigm of of let's say survival
analysis regression based Cox
proportional Hazard this is very basic
majority of the methods in the machine
learning uh side they are built on top
of the uh loss function the log
likelihood function that this method is
trying to optimize
so in this method what you would have is
basically a hazard function t for
features throughout time h h0 t so
that's a Time varing parameter that's
your Baseline Hazard and E with the
power of B transpose X so the BR
transpose X give you the flavor of this
regression
like but the h0 t is basically what
you're trying to uh let's say estimate
in this so it's a Time varying Hazard
it's
constant for all of your basically uh
samples that's how the Cox is relaxing
this and it tries to propagate this
Baseline Hazard based on the feature by
multiplying e with the power of B
transpose X to it so if you use the htx
over h0t and do a log then it's
basically a simple regression exert a
variables B are the um the the
coefficients and the h0o is the Baseline
which is a non- negative parameter that
you try to uh
estimate if you look at this basically a
probability of Hazard for patient let's
say one or customer one HT X1 HT X2 over
one another is basically the time
varying term that's canceling itself out
and it's basically
the the difference between these
subjects is on the the features so this
this is how Cox is trying to address
this basically considering a let's say a
baseline Hazard for all of the
samples an example of this is the same
data set
um uh yeah
prisoners when you fit this uh with with
Cox what you would see is basically the
features the variables uh financial aid
received yes or no age work experience
marriage prior arrest parle
so for example when you look at the
samples you see even with the power of
BX if it's bigger than one it kind of
give you a flavor that uh having for
example prior arrest is 9% more risk of
getting rearrested however receiving a
financial less is support 30% less and
and so on so forth age as well marriage
of course less uh uh given the data
chance of getting rearrested but then
what you're doing in the above case is
just basically you're doing a
multivariate feature analysis of course
um and then you could also be interested
in the predicting the time actually that
the prisoners are getting rearrested
this could be also predicting the time
that your marketing campaign based on
your marketing campaign your customers
are getting
converted and then that's again within
the survival Community that's a that's a
basically a function throughout time so
uh which is not similar to regression
and classification which is single point
then you are here basically trying to
predict a function throughout
time so what about the other methods in
the community so now we're moving
gradually a little bit to machine
learning based methods um we have let's
say decision uh trees of course what we
do with those methods we try to minimize
a metric of Choice by liting the data
into leaves and we continue that for for
classification we look at for example
Gene index entropy for regression sum of
square error but then what is different
with the Survival let's say Tre is
basically they're looking at the P value
of the rock rank test so the same P
value that would show you the koua curve
how different it is so that would be a
good candidate if the the P value was a
small this the the the the the
difference is significant then uh
probably there split is a good split and
so on so forth um there are
implementation of this in sarus survival
of course based on this you could uh
grow your your your you could bootstrap
and grow number of trees and uh and
number of decision trees and and and
move forward and do a majority voting by
aggregating the cumulative Hazard
function that's also the other candidate
function next to survival that you could
use and basically you could do a variant
of survival f Forest like random forest
and of course you could continue this
with many other methods by by looking at
more advanced and sophisticated but the
Baseline is basically the same just
looking at the different
metrics implementation of this is
available also in uh extreme let's say
in the exus package you could look up
there are examples of implementation as
well so we we discussed majority of the
uh basically the methods that they would
deal with tabular data structured data
however there could be a case that
you're dealing with unstructured data
for example you are trying to use the
let's say handwritten note of your
client to predict the time that they
would churn or you would have image of
an MRI and you are trying to predict if
the if the situation of a patient could
get complicated or they would revisit
the intensive care or something like
that you are basically then dealing with
unstructured data and of course you want
to employ try to reuse the existing body
of let's say methods let's say uh
initial layers that are already built
for text analytics image analytics and
incorporate that with basically survival
analysis that's also possible it's not
very different because basically what
you would do you try to look at the C
proportional has a partial log loss
function uh that would be your candidate
loss function in dealing with also
basically neural based uh methods so
then there is a standard and basic
method of on this line this deep serve
building on top of
this so basically uh we went over the um
yeah methods in survival analysis the
whole motivation uh for this talk is to
uh kind of promote survival analysis
methods so that uh people and audience
could give it a try and see if it would
be relevant in their let's say
context and of course there are many
implementation available in Python so
there wouldn't be a lot of hassle trying
to uh using these uh start off with very
simple and basic methods uh klamer is a
very good candidate to start um of
course you could go to the treebase
methods Ensemble methods of course deep
learning would probably would be your
last given the complication if you are
dealing with unstructured data but for
tabular one it's already U the basic
methods already providing quite some
added value um if you're interested to
read further about this topic uh there
are um there are surveys and slides by
uh some researchers from Virginia Tech
the the the examples and the
documentation of Lifeline that's a
packaging closer to statistical
Community that's fantastic uh also
psychic survival and pyx these are
packages developed by some PhD student
during their research those are also
interested interesting you could have a
look at those for uh relevant
implementation in your case
um thank you so much for your um yeah uh
presence I hope uh it was something in
it for you something that could trigger
you to may maybe use um survival
analysis methods more and um yeah so we
have uh also openings in our team at ABN
umro uh in marketing weth management
marketing in case you're interested uh
let me know
yeah thanks for your
attention